Psychologists make a distinction between three different types of affective
experiences. We should first state that the word affect, is in an umbrella term
used to cover all emotional experiences, including emotions, moods, and
affective states. Let's start with emotions. Emotions are brief, sudden changes
in our conscious experience and body that are responses to personally
meaningful situations. We feel emotion about very specific situations. Such as
when we fail an exam, get an A on an exam, break up with our significant other,
or have something stolen from us. Emotions are very short lived, typically
lasting no more than 30 seconds to 1 minute. At most. They focus our attention
and guide our memory, perception, and decision making. Think about how you
learn if you're really angry or depressed, or the kind of buying decisions you
make when you're really happy, compared to when you're really sad. The actual
experience of anger, disgust, happiness, or fear, for example, usually last
only a short period of time. They can lead to other emotions, though. For
example, sometimes we get angry at ourselves for feel jealous or embarrassed.